hey this is presh talwalkar
abcd is a trapezoid
a b is parallel to c d and a b is
greater than c d
let p be a point in the interior of the
trapezoid and connect it to the four
vertices dividing the trapezoid into
four triangles
suppose triangle cpd has an area equal
to two then the areas of the triangles
going clockwise are equal to three
four and five as shown
the question is what is a b divided by c
d equal to
i thank an a for the suggestion
a version of this problem appeared on
the 2021 amc 12b which is a math
competition given to high school
students in america
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
to solve this problem construct a
perpendicular between the side cd and ab
that goes through the point p
let the distance between point p and a b
be equal to x and let the distance
between p and c d be equal to y
since triangle apb has an area equal to
4
x times a b is equal to two times four
since triangle cpd has an area equal to
two
y times c d is equal to two times two
then consider the entire trapezoid
considering its area we have the
quantity x plus y
multiplied by the quantity a b plus c d
is equal to two multiplied by two plus
three plus four plus five
we now have three equations let's focus
on these three equations
first two plus three plus four plus five
is equal to fourteen
we'll then simplify the right hand side
of each equation
now let's solve for x in the second
equation
let's solve for y in the third equation
we can then substitute these into the
first equation
so we will have the quantity eight over
a b
plus four over c d
multiplied by the quantity a b plus c d
is equal to twenty eight
we can now distribute
then we have eight plus four on the left
hand side which is equal to 12. so we
subtract 12 from both sides
we can then divide the entire equation
by 4.
this gives 2 multiplied by c d over a b
plus a b over c d is equal to 4. let's
focus on this equation
let z be equal to a b over c d
then c d over a b is equal to 1 over z
so we have 2 multiplied by 1 over z plus
z is equal to four
multiply the entire equation by z
and then subtract four z from both sides
we have z squared minus four z plus two
is equal to zero
we can solve this quadratic equation and
we get two possible values for z
so which one is it
we have a b over c d is either 2 plus
the square root of 2 or 2 minus the
square root of 2.
we were given that a b is greater than c
d
so we must take the plus value so that
the ratio is greater than 1.
thus a b over c d is equal to two plus
the square root of two
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time